probably my favorite scene in the movie
is the one between the two of you Did
you sort of know it on the day that you
were doing something special I think
what's so beautiful about it is the is
the tenderness of Jim's performance and
the tenderness of the of the of the
writing as well an awful lot of queer
stories I think aren't um coming out
story certainly aren't um perhaps as
Extreme as as many people experience
that there's um it's not full embraced
acceptance or nor is it um outright
rejection it's somewhere in between and
that's thorny and I think that happens
not just and in queer families but in
all our families and I think that's
what's very I think that's what pierces
the hearts of the audiences